des interventions policières remplacées
par des interventions sociales ce ne
sont pas des militants pour le
défiancement de la police qui le propose
c'est ce sur quoi misent le ministère de
la Sécurité publique quand l'un verront
30% des appels au 91 ici à Montréal sont
des appels reliés à la santé mentale des
appels des situations qui deviennent des
problèmes de sécurité publique et qui
deviennent un peu sur les bras de nos
policiers mais qui ne sont pas des
interventions de sécurité publique cette
unité d'intervenance socio qui viendrait
soulager les policiers existent déjà
depuis un an à Montréal
un projet pilote dans le centre-ville
qui sera étendu à toute la métropole
grâce à 25 millions de dollars de Québec
et autant de Montréal
nous avons suivi deux patrouilles de
l'hémis l'équipe mobile de médiation et
d'intervention sociale clairement on est
à long voyageur on est juste à côté de
la station berrican aux abords du parc
Émilie Gamelin en fait donc c'est un
secteur évidence où il y a beaucoup
d'activités qu'il y a beaucoup de
mouvements des va-et-vient tant de
personnes en situation d'itinérance que
de personnes vulnérables après moins de
10 minutes en compagnie de Sébastien et
Camille
le duo d'intervenants va répondre aux
inquiétudes d'un citoyen lié à la vente
de drogue on a fait on a lâché des
appels beaucoup d'appels quand il y
avait des indésirables dans des escalier
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire nous évidemment
on va inclure ce secteur à nos
patrouilles concierge à côté c'est piqué
deux fois en ramassant il s'est retrouvé
à l'hôpital on va être là pour aller
vérifier si des strings nous par la
suite on va se mettre en contact avec
les travailleurs de rue du secteur
réaction du citoyen face à cette prise
en charge par des intervenants plutôt
que des policiers plus il y a de gens
concernés plus de gens qui nous
entendent plus on risque de de
solutionner le problème ça va permettre
aux policiers de se décharger d'un
travail qui n'est pas nécessairement le
leur qui peut être parfois difficile
pour les policiers d'aller mobiliser les
équipes les services communautaires mis
à leur disposition nous on a des bons
liens avec tout ce qui est le
communautaire Kelly et Lucie elle se
démène pour venir en aide à une famille
de Turcs signalée à la gare Windsor nous
de trouver en ce moment c'est des
vêtements et des couvertures pour cette
famille puis surtout pour les enfants
accompagné un jeune toxicoman pour une
injection supervisée pendant que Lucie
cherche un transport pour un autre homme
dans le besoin Kelly découvre la raison
qui pousse leur passager à consommer
au refuge gifabro
le temps c'est ce luxe qui manque aux
policiers et qui donne tout son sens à
cette nouvelle équipe
les deux intervenantes ne laisseront pas
leur usagers seuls très longtemps elles
auront juste le temps de s'occuper du
matériel pour la famille turque
45 minutes on injection le présentement
une policière par exemple va prendre une
personne des organisée voire une urgence
de l'hôpital voilà laisser là on va
quitter vous doit aller faire d'autres
appels et la personne voit souvent se
retrouver dans la rue quelques heures
plus tard bonne nouvelle pour les Turcs
quelques instants plus tard un organisme
pour réfugier leur ouvre ses portes
au coucher des réfugiés des itinérants
des femmes battues
en ce moment là on patch plein de trous
depuis un an les miss a géré une moyenne
de 15 situations par jour la moitié des
appels provenait d'organismes
communautaires et un tiers du SPVM mais
une répartition directe par le 91 est à
l'étude et il y a aussi des
interventions spontanées
[Musique]
au bon moment parce que cette personne
c'est s'avérait qu'elle avait vraiment
besoin d'être puis je suis interaction
puis le la personne s'est ouverte avec
le financement émise devrait compter une
cinquantaine d'intervenants contre une
dizaine aujourd'hui ils seront
disponibles 24 heures sur 24 7 jours sur
7 et les interventions ne seront pas
nécessairement les mêmes sur tout le
territoire Montréal faut vraiment
s'assurer que ça va prendre gérer la
couleur de l'arrondissement ou de
l'environnement
par exemple on peut penser si ça va je
sais pas Montréal Nord mais c'est
peut-être des incivilités dans le parc
avec les jeunes mais avec un seul souci
en tête pour celles et ceux qui
arpentent les rues j'ai l'impression que
on fait un petit changement dans la vie
de quelqu'un puisse je pense que c'est
la valeur ajoutée pour moi